-Recordings have surfaced
of Trump begging
Georgia Secretary of State
Brad Raffensperger
to overturn the results
of the election
after he lost
to President-elect Joe Biden
It's becoming increasingly clear
that Trump is willing
to do anything
to get what he wants.
-Say there, young one.
Who are you talking about?
-Well, who are you?
-Me?
I'm just an R&B singer
from the '50s looking
for inspiration
for my next hit song.
-Oh. I'm just talking
about a guy named Donald Trump
-Oh, sounds like
a real desperate guy.
-[ Laughing ] Oh!
Boy, oh boy, is he ever.
-Well, tell me about it.
-Okay.
He makes those old songs
about heartbreak
sound like a walk in the park.
This guy's so desperate,
he spent an hour on the phone,
begging for votes.
-[ Laughs ]
That is good.
What you just said there, son,
that's inspiration.
[ Upbeat tune plays ]
♪♪ Girl, I'd spend hours ♪♪
♪♪ begging, pleading like
a low-down dirty dog ♪♪
♪♪ I'd suffer all kinds
of humiliation ♪♪
♪♪ I'd do whatever it takes
♪♪ To keep you around, darling
♪♪ Got a bad case
of desperation ♪♪
♪♪♪♪
-Wow!
He does make a good song.
-Yeah.
Tell me more about this guy.
-Oh, man, I don't know.
Well, he's not very honest
-[ Laughs ] Yeah, now there?
That's a good one.
♪♪♪♪
[ Laughter ]
♪♪ Baby, I would beg,
steal, cheat ♪♪
♪♪ I'd even lie
to win you back ♪♪
♪♪ Right here, right now ♪♪
♪♪ I'd even win you back
through ♪♪
♪♪ Being honest, baby, but
♪♪ I just don't know how ♪♪
♪♪♪♪
-Whoo!
You're really cooking now.
You got that right.
Hey, what else?
-Okay, well, think
about any bad person.
-Uh-huh.
-Well, whatever's true
about them
is also likely true of him
-Okay.
Let me know if I'm off
in any way, alright?
♪♪♪♪
♪♪ Baby, I'm always
telling tales ♪♪
♪♪ I deserve to be in jail
♪♪ I'm a grifter and it shows
♪♪ And I wear
ill-fitting clothes ♪♪
-Wow!
You really have it down.
-Yeah, I do.
Tell me more!
-Well, he's not the brightest.
♪♪♪♪
-♪♪ I may be dumb ♪♪
-Kind of mean.
-♪♪ I may be mean ♪♪
-Kind of gross-looking.
♪♪ I may be the ugliest ma
you've ever seen ♪♪
♪♪ But I will always have
♪♪ an unhealthy
obsession with you ♪♪
♪♪ It's the only thing
I've said ♪♪
♪♪ That is even remotely true
♪♪♪♪
[ Laughter ]
Hey, what is this guy's
big problem, anyway?
-He lost an election.
♪♪♪♪
[ Laughter ]
-♪♪ Oh, baby, I can't ♪♪
♪♪ Let you go ♪♪
♪♪ I wanna give you my love
♪♪ And affection ♪♪
♪♪ I will not let you go ♪♪
♪♪ 'Cause you're my one
and only ♪♪
♪♪ You're my one and only
♪♪ Election ♪♪
♪♪ Ahhhhhhhhhhhhh! ♪♪
♪♪♪♪
Hey, we did it!
We wrote a whole song.
Hey, young one,
thanks for all your help.
-Hey, you're welcome.
And you never told me your name.
-That's because I might be
a drea-ea-ea-m.
-Wow.
You're still here.
-Yeah.
I said I might be a dream.
-Oh.
So what's your name?
-Karl-l-l.
-Alright, well, just tell me
[ Laughter ]
Give it up for Karl, everybody